Well, good morning.
Well, that was good. It was good to, good
to see you once again.
And I always love coming to Henderson Hills.
Uh, John, I've known for a very, very long time, uh,
before actually I moved to Oklahoma.
John was one of my students, uh, in a demon, uh,
seminar, if I'm not mistaken.
And it was great. Uh, not demon, not demon
doctor of ministry, I think it was.
And, uh, anyway, it's great to be with him
and I'm so grateful, uh, to your pastor for the invitation.
And it's great that you guys are studying. First Samuel.
I love First Samuel. How many
of you have really enjoyed this series on First Samuel?
I have, yeah. It's great hearing, uh,
what God is doing in the life of this church.
And really, when we open God's word, uh,
unbelievable things happen.
It's no wonder that the Bible is described
as sharper than a two-edged sword.
It's able to cleave joint and marrow.
I mean, that's pretty powerful
when we think about the word of God.
And, uh, there's a reason why it's described that way,
because indeed it cuts us asunder.
It, it opens us up, it lays bare our intentions,
our hidden desires,
and all of the things that are deep inside of us.
It opens all of that up.
And that's actually what's gonna happen today
as we look at one Samuel Chapter 14.
So I'm gonna ask you if you have your Bible, go ahead
and open to one Samuel 14, uh,
because that's the passage that we're going
to be exploring today.
And the way that we're gonna approach this is I'm gonna
read, uh, really verses 24 through 52.
That's a lot of text, so hang with me.
But I'm gonna be referring back to verses one through 23.
And what you need to understand about this passage
of scripture is this is a, uh, uh,
basically a little embedded story about
Jonathan and Saul.
Saul is the king of Israel. Jonathan is his son.
And actually this story of Saul
and Jonathan begins
with a focus on Jonathan in verses one through 23.
And then it turns to Saul in verses 24 through 52.
So I'm gonna be referring to Saul and Jonathan
because what the text actually does is establishes a
contrast between the life and the intention, the desire
and the faith of Jonathan versus the life, the intention,
the desire, and the faith of Saul.
And when we look at these two figures,
we see a little bit of ourselves.
So we're gonna look at that together.
Now, what you need to understand about first
and second Samuel is they're really actually one book.
And they tell the story of the rise
of the king in Israel.
And, uh, it's not just the king, any old king.
It's the king that God desires.
And so it opens with this story about
a woman named Hannah who can't have a baby,
and God does something miraculous on her behalf.
And she sings a song in, uh, first Samuel chapter two.
And that embedded in there, she talks about the king.
And then in second Samuel 22, uh, second Samuel, chapter 22
and 23, 1 of the things that you see is at the end of that,
there's another little, uh, poem,
and it's sung by David.
And in there he talks about the king.
The reason this is important is
because it's almost like the bookends of the, of this book
talk about the king
and how God is the rock that we can trust
and he's gonna raise up a king.
And so it raises this question, who is this king?
And the rest of one and two Samuel? Play that out.
Here we are in one Samuel 14,
Saul has been anointed as king over Israel.
And yet in chapter 13, which you may remember,
Saul has been rejected as king.
And then 14, you have the story we're gonna look at today.
And then in chapter 15, more bad news for Saul.
So already in the kind of the frame
around verse chapter 14, you get
negative portraits about Saul.
And that's important because that helps us understand how
to read Saul's actions.
How many of you like movies?
Or how many of you like to watch videos on your device?
Anybody? If you like your device, raise, flash it at me.
Somebody's on Netflix right now. That's rude.
What you need to understand about what you need
to understand about, uh, biblical narrative, like first,
second Samuel, we like to think that it's, uh,
telling us everything.
But if you could imagine,
and you might want to do this right now,
I give you permission to do this.
Uh, turn on your, if you've got your, your, your device,
turn on your, uh, your video.
I've got mine on, right? I'm looking at myself now.
It's looking at you, right?
Turn on your video, and I want you
to look like scan my, the stage.
Do it right. Now, this is very important.
Make your own little movie. Don't take pictures of me.
I haven't authorized that, right? But take a look.
If you were watching a little video
or creating a video, this is what you need to understand.
As you move around, you're setting the frame on what's
important and what's not.
You can zoom in, you can zoom out, you can say,
I'll only show this bit, but I'm not gonna show that bit.
How do you do that? You do this through your camera.
So you and I both understand how to set different kind of,
uh, layers of focus on our devices.
What you need to understand is in the biblical
text, it does the same thing.
It doesn't tell us everything about Saul's life
or his reign, or David's life or his reign.
It really zooms in and frames up certain situations
or certain stories in the life of Saul or of David
or of Jonathan, to tell the story.
And what is the story? This is the story.
Who is the king that Israel needs?
And so what we're gonna talk about today is lessons.
In fact, we're gonna have seven lessons from the story of
Saul and Jonathan that help us understand
the king we need.
Okay? You with me? Alright.
Open your Bible to one Samuel Chapter 14.
Now, what you need to understand is in verses one
through 23, Jonathan has instigated a fight
with the Philistines.
And in this fight, God does this miraculous, uh, victory.
And then the fight continues
and it continues, and it continues.
And now in verse 23
and 24, we see the the fight is continuing on and
and God's people are, are,
are really pursuing the Philistines.
So the battle extends beyond Beth Aven
and the men of Israel were worn out that day.
Now, why were they worn out from fighting? Well, not really.
The reason that they're worn out is not just
because of the fight, but
because of this, Paul, uh, Saul
had placed the troops under an O oath.
The man who eats food before evening
before I've taken vengeance on my enemies is cursed.
You might wanna underline that verse. Why?
Because it reveals a little bit about Saul
and what's important to him.
So none of the troops tasted any food.
Verse 25, everyone went into the forest
and there was honey on the ground.
So they, he's just uttered this oak, this vow.
He said, if anybody eats food from my army,
you're gonna be a curse.
They go into the forest, and guess what?
There's food on the ground. What is it, honey?
And when the troops entered the forest, they saw the flow
of honey, but none of them ate any of it
because they feared the oath that Saul had made.
However, Jonathan, you remember, Jonathan is Saul's son.
He hadn't heard his father make the oath
or the troops swear the oath.
So he reached out with the end of his staff,
he was carrying, dipped it into the honeycomb.
And when he ate the honey, uh,
the Bible says his eyes lit up,
or, uh, he had light in his eyes.
It basically, he revived himself. He renewed his energy.
Then one of the troops said,
your father made the troops solemnly swear.
The man who eats food today is cursed
and the troops are exhausted.
Jonathan replied, my father has brought trouble to the land.
Underline that phrase,
my father has brought trouble to the land.
Just look at how I've renewed energy
because I tasted a little of this, honey.
How much better? If the troops had eaten freely from the
plunder they took from their enemies, then the slaughter,
the Philistines would've been much greater.
Then you have a summary statement.
The, the Israelites struck down the Philistines
that day from Mik mash all the way the Agilon,
since the Israelites were completely exhausted, they rushed
to the plunder, took sheep, goats, cattle calves,
slaughtered them on the ground, ate meat
with the blood still in it.
Now, just so we're clear, this, uh, the,
the chase from mash all the way the a agilon is, um,
it's about 15 miles.
So imagine chasing an army through hill country,
over rocks and terrain fighting for 15 miles all day.
I mean, I've got two kids at home still.
Two of my kids are in college, two of my kids are at home.
And, uh, they're, they're not fighting all well, most
of the time they're not fighting all day.
But I'm just thinking about my son.
The amount of food he eats on a normal day is shocking.
I I cannot imagine how famished
these warriors would be if they were chasing
and fighting for 15 miles all day long.
And their king had said, you can't eat any food.
Well, guess what happens? The day is up.
They start seeing all the plunder, the Philistines,
and that is the animals.
And they say, we're really hungry.
'cause we said that we wouldn't eat and we haven't eaten.
The day is over, now we're going to eat.
And so they begin to slaughter all of the sheep
and the goats and the cattle and the calves on the ground
and ate meat with the blood still in it.
Now, why is that significant?
What they did is they were so hungry
and famish, they took the animals
and they put 'em on the ground and slaughtered them.
Normally what would happen is you would hang it according
to Israelite law so that the blood would drain out,
and that was how it was supposed to be done.
So when it says they eat the, they ate the meat
with the blood still in it,
it means they made the slaughter on the ground
and they were so hungry, they just quickly
made a quick slaughter, didn't drain the meat,
drained the blood, which was a violation of the law.
And that's bad, okay?
So Somem reported to Saul, look,
the troops are sinning against the Lord
by eating meat with the blood in it.
And Saul said, you've been unfaithful,
roll a large stone over here at once.
And then he said, go among the troops
and say to them, let each man bring me his ous sheep,
do the slaughtering here on this stone
so it's not on the ground.
So the blood can drain out a little bit.
Do do the slaughtering here,
and then you can eat, don't sin against the Lord
by eating meat with the blood in it.
So every one of the troops brought his ox that night
and slaughtered it there.
Then Saul built an altar to the Lord.
It was the first time he had built an altar to the Lord.
Now that's an interesting note.
This is the first time as king,
he has built an altar to the Lord.
We'll come back to that. Saul said, let's go down
after the Philistines tonight
and plum to them until morning.
Don't even let one remain. Do whatever you want.
The troops replied.
But the priest said, well, I think we,
we should approach God, the here.
So Saul inquired of God, and he said, should I go
after the Philistines?
Will you hand them over to Israel? Now look at what happens.
He asked God because the priest encouraged him to do so,
whether he should go into battle.
And he said, you know, are the
Philistines gonna be handed over?
And God didn't answer.
Saul said, verse 38, all the, all, all you leaders
of the troops come here.
Let's investigate.
Let's figure out how this sin has occurred today.
And then he makes another vow.
Remember the first vow was, if anybody eats food today,
before I have vengeance on my
enemies, you're gonna be cursed.
Now, he makes another vow that's rash.
And he says this, as surely as the Lord lives,
who sa saves Israel, even if it's
because of my son, Jonathan, that did the sin
that prevents God from answering Saul.
He says, even if it's Jonathan, that person must die.
Not one of the troops answered him.
So he said to all Israel, you'll be on one side, and my
and my son, Jonathan will be,
and I am my son, Jonathan will be on the other side.
And the troops replied, do whatever you want.
So Saul said to the Lord, God of Israel,
why have you not answered your servant today?
If the unrighteousness is in me
or my son, Jonathan Lord God of Israel, give orim.
But if the fault is your people, Israel give tome.
This is the rum and the thme.
It is, uh, it's a way of discerning the will of God.
And they little stones.
One is, um, more of a whitish color
and one is a darker color.
And if you get the darker color,
you're the one who's in trouble.
And if you get the whiter color of the rock,
then you're clear.
Well, guess what happened?
Jonathan and Saul were selected
and the troops were clear to the charge.
Then Saul said, cast the lot between me,
my, my son, Jonathan.
And Jonathan was selected. Saul commanded him.
Tell me what you did.
So Jonathan said to him, well, I tasted a little honey
with the end of my staff, I was carrying, I'm ready to die.
Saul declared to him, may God punish me and do so severely.
If you do not die, Jonathan.
And then all of a sudden, guess what happens?
The people say to Saul, must Jonathan die?
He accomplished such a great deliverance for Israel.
No, as the Lord lives, not a hair of his head will fall
to the ground for he worked with God's help today.
So the people redeemed Jonathan
and he didn't die.
Then Saul gave up the pursuit of the Philistines,
and the Philistines returned to their own territory.
And then you have a summary statement
of Saul's kingship that says this.
When Saul assumed kingship over Israel,
he fought against all his enemies,
all his enemies in every direction.
Moab the Ammonites, Edem, the kings
of Zah and the Philistines.
Wherever he turned, he caused havoc.
He fought, bravely, defeated the Amalekites
and rescued Israel from those who plundered them.
Sauls sons were Jonathan ish
and, uh, Mahua, the names of his two daughters were Meab,
his firstborn and Michal.
The the younger, the name of Saul's wife was, I know him,
the daughter of Aima.
The name of the commander of his army was Abner's, son
of Saul's, uncle n You're gonna
remember all these names, right?
Saul's father was Kish, Abner's father was na son of Aviel.
The conflict with the Philistines was
fierce, all of Saul's day.
So whenever Saul noticed any strong
or valiant man, he enlisted him.
Now, what you need to focus on is this opening,
uh, verse verse 24, where Saul says,
I'm gonna take vengeance on my enemies.
And, uh, you can't eat any food.
And if you do before I take vengeance on my enemies, uh,
you know you're cursed.
That's the rash vowel.
Verse 24, the concluding sec, uh, verse of this section.
Verse 20, uh, 52, Saul, the text says,
Saul fighting men.
And whenever he saw one, he goes, I, uh, you're on my team.
Now that means good strategy, right?
If he's a king, he wants to,
but it tells us a little bit something about Saul.
He's worried about his enemies,
he's worried about his kingdom.
He's worried about bringing people to his side.
And the text is framing up through those pronouns.
I, me, my Saul's
heart, it's about him.
But who's the book of one Samuel about God
and the king that God will bring?
We'll, we'll unpack that in just a minute.
So this passage of scripture is really important
and it, it shows us some lessons
that we need to learn.
Okay? Here's the first lesson.
It comes in verses one through 23,
and it contrasts against Saul and his perspective.
And it's the lesson of perhaps the power
of perhaps
P-E-R-H-A-P-S perhaps.
Now, Saul, according to the text,
his focus really is on himself.
And because of that, he has a tendency
to treat God in a very particular way as a means to his end.
Jonathan, by contrast, has a relationship with God.
He doesn't treat God like a screwdriver
that he can use to get what he wants.
He treats God like God, the one
with whom he must deal, the one
with whom he has a relationship.
And Jonathan's relationship
with God is real in evident in the ways
that he speaks about God.
So if you have your Bible, turn back
to the beginning of chapter 14.
And if you look around verse
six, you get a little glimpse into the,
the heart of Jonathan.
He talks to his armor bearer.
It's just he and his armor bearer.
He is looking up at the garrison
of the Philistines up on a hill
and he says, you know, I think we should go take that.
I mean, after all, they're up there.
Let's see if we can go take it.
And he says this, come let us.
This is verse six of chapter 14.
Let us go over to the garrison of these uncircumcised.
That is the Philistines.
And in the ESV, the English standard version,
it translates the Hebrew.
This way. It may be that the Lord will work for us,
for nothing can hinder the Lord from saving
by many or by few.
In other versions, that phrase it may be is translated.
Perhaps it's the Hebrew word, ULA.
If you're interested, most of you aren't,
and that's fine, right?
It's this Hebrew word, ula, perhaps, perhaps
it shows up in key moments in actually in the Old Testament.
Uh, when the Neite king in the book of Jonah
is facing obliteration
and Jonah has preached, the king goes, well,
I think we should repent.
I mean, after all, perhaps God will save us.
Perhaps God is free to do whatever he wants.
God can save as Jonathan says, by many whole big army
or at, in this case, in verses one through 23, God can save
with the king's son, Jonathan and his armor bearer.
Few, God's free to do whatever he wants.
Why does Jonathan know that?
Because he has a relationship with God.
Saul wants to manipulate God to his side.
Jonathan just wants to walk in his relationship with God.
So this language of perhaps opens us up to that truth.
It may be that God will give deliverance this day.
He can do it with a few, or he can do it with many.
Why does Jonathan use this language of perhaps
because he knows God, he rightly states
that God can save?
That's true. And it's true that God can save with many
an army or a few.
That's true. God can use a small group to do mighty things.
After all, Gideon, in the book of Judges,
God uses small group to conquer a many people.
Or think about the 12 disciples.
12 people changed the world.
God can use few or he can use many.
Look at the church today, few people with maximum impact,
but sometimes God uses many people to impact many.
It's the free choice of God, which he will use
and which he will choose to use at whichever time, according
to his own will, his own desire, his own pleasure.
He's God. So it's true that God will use Jonathan
and his armor bearer.
That's true. Or is it Jonathan doesn't know.
He says, well, if you look at the story of Israel,
he could do either so perhaps he'll use us.
Perhaps he won. It's up to the free choice of God.
Jonathan is not trying to make God
do something.
He recognizes who God is.
He recognizes God is utterly free in his relationship
with you and his relationship with me.
So what's grounding his faith? He knows God.
He trusts God. He's in relationship with God.
So he is able to confirm
and affirm the truth of God while leaving God free to do
what he wants to do in his situation.
It's the power of perhaps, eh, I don't know. Perhaps.
We'll see. I trust him either way.
Saul is very different than Jonathan.
Saul's purpose is to get vengeance on his enemies. Verse 24.
And so what he's doing throughout this passage
is using religious stuff to get
God to act.
You know what it's like? How many of you like, uh,
gumball machines?
I like gumball machines.
In fact, there's a picture of a gumball machine.
Oftentimes we treat God like a glorified
gumball machine.
I'll put my quarter of faith in, manipulate God to act
so I can get what I want.
My gumball. But God is not a gumball machine.
There's always, perhaps, I don't know
either way, I trust God.
Isn't that true? In the life of faith, wherever you remember
that old song, wherever he leads, I'll go.
He may lead us here. He may lead us there.
He may heal, he may provide ultimate healing in heaven.
God is free. We're contingent.
So what does God invite us to do?
Trust him in relationship with him.
The more that we have a close relationship, we see, we see
that God is better than anything.
And so Jonathan was content to say perhaps.
I mean, if we go up and we die, who cares? I trust him.
Saul, by contrast, wants to use God.
What about you? What about me?
Do we understand the power of perhaps?
Are we trying to manipulate God? Just a question.
It's a lesson we must learn.
Lesson two, faith matters
most talked about Jonathan's relationship with God draws us
to con consider this truth about faith.
It matters most. Saul is worried about position.
Saul is worried about power.
Saul is worried about his enemies. Notice the language.
It's always first person. It's my enemies. His enemies.
It's all about Saul.
Saul is worried about position, reputation, power,
the people he is gonna get vengeance against.
Do you know what it's not about With Saul?
Faith in God.
Faith however matters most Jonathan's relationship
with God contrasts against Saul
and reminds us that position doesn't matter.
Most money doesn't matter.
Most enemies don't matter most.
The fear of others or the respect of others does not matter.
Most victory does not matter.
Most faith in the God
who made us matters most.
You see, Jonathan is presented
as a faithful follower of the Lord.
Saul, not so much.
So let's do a heart check when it comes to this question
of faith, shall we?
How are we doing on the lesson of faith matters most.
Let's do a self inventory. I'm a teacher by training.
And so one of the things that we like to do is assessments.
If you were to assess your heart
and your life, I mean honestly,
what are those temptations that seem to rise
above faith?
We've just come from a Saturday, and I don't know about you,
but, uh, it was a an extraordinarily challenging day
for the state of Oklahoma.
And
sometimes when it's an extraordinarily challenging day
for the state of Oklahoma on a Saturday,
we come in here on a Sunday and we feel defeated.
But can I ask you something?
In the grand scheme of things,
do defeats on the football field
defeat our faith?
Come on. We get excited on a Saturday
and we're somber on a Sunday,
and maybe we need to do an assessment about which is most
weighty in our lives.
Can I get in your business a little bit?
You can't fire me, so whatever, right?
Which is most important.
What we're trying to do, for instance, at OBU, is I'm trying
to help our community understand faith matters most.
Uh, be a doctor, be an engineer, uh, be an attorney,
be a physical therapist, great.
Do all of that. But as God uses you in those fields,
live all of life with deep faith,
strong hands, right?
Full hearts, wise minds.
Faith matters most faith animates our life.
Faith, faith animates our work.
Faith in Jesus, not in ourselves. Amen.
Faith matters most. Here's the third lesson. I love that.
I love this. This is, I'm gonna spend a little bit
of time on this, so just hang with me.
Religion can be a mask.
Lesson number three, religion can be a mask.
Now, I like this because it's so evocative
of our current world.
In verse 35, in this passage, one of the things
that we note is Saul builds antar.
Now, on the face of it, building an altar is a good thing.
Whenever the saints of old encountered
God, guess what they did?
They built an altar to commemorate what God had done.
Think about Abram, when he built an altar between Bethel
and AI to commemorate God's guidance to the promised land.
And there at the altar where he built that place
and commemorated God's kindness
and his graciousness, he called on the name of the Lord.
Worship an altar is a beautiful thing.
In those instances, altars are an expression
of a deep relationship where God has proven, faithful
to an individual or to a family.
Altars are good.
However, the altar here,
we've got questions about it.
Why is he building an altar?
Well, in this context, we don't see a lot about his
devotion to the Lord.
Chapter 13, he's kind of doing some weird stuff.
In chapter 13, the beginning of chapter 14 is Jonathan,
who's going out in faithfulness, the beginning
of our section today, verse 2024.
Saul is more focused than anything on his vengeance.
So why is he building an altar to God?
It looks like, and this is the nature
of biblical narrative, it's subtle.
It shows an action and says, think about that.
Well, let's think about this.
Why is he building an altar to glorify?
God doesn't look that way.
It looks like he's building an altar to try
and manipulate God so he can get his vengeance.
He inquires of the priest
after the priest says, you should do this.
He's not really attuned to the things of God.
And this is a great reminder for us
that religion can oftentimes mask
deeper sin issues in our lives.
In fact, if you look at Saul's life in this passage,
he tells his people that they shouldn't eat food.
That's crazy. The law didn't demand this,
didn't demand, uh, you know, self-denial of food.
So what's he concerned about?
He's certainly not concerned about the good of his soldiers.
He's concerned about his vengeance.
He's not the concerned about the good
of God's name in God's glory.
It looks like he's building an altar for his own name so
that he can manipulate God and he can get his vengeance.
He's concerned about himself.
He's concerned about his kingdom.
He's concerned about his vengeance,
but he's not necessarily concerned about God.
He uses religion as a mask to hide his intentions.
Sacrifice alter inquiring of God,
having a priest hanging around.
These are all external things.
Masks that hide his true worship.
Saul, like many of us, worships at the altar of me,
myself and I,
and he's engaging that false worship in the midst
of the people of God.
It's pure evil. How does this happen where
religion masks pure evil?
How does that happen? I'm reminded
of a psychologist called M Scott p
and one of the things that he says is,
many times in the life of a church
or religious groups,
you find just abhorrent things going on,
but they look good from the outside.
It, it just, it doesn't make any sense.
But then because he is a Christian psychologist,
he draws our attention to Lucifer.
You remember Lucifer Wright, son of the morning,
the other name for Satan,
the angel who's rebelled against God gets defeated.
You remember, do you remember what Lucifer looks like?
Well, if you think about William Blake, that great poet, uh,
American poet, he used to do these prints.
And one of the things that he did,
and I think I have a a picture of it,
Lucifer, uh, there he is.
He's beautiful, he's glorious.
He's Linds, he's bright,
and yet pure evil.
Why? Because religion can mask.
We put up this false front
and friends, the church is not a perfect place.
It's oftentimes not even the most beautiful
place on the outside.
It's a bunch of broken people recognizing we have desperate
need and that me need is met in one person, Jesus.
And so we can be honest. We can be open.
We don't have to put up false fronts.
Saul, on the other hand, is using religion as a mask
to hide his sin.
Lesson number four, God is greater.
Jonathan recognizes that God is greater than a Philistine.
He says, Hey, God is free to do whatever he wants.
Wants God can deliver with a big army or a small group.
Doesn't make any difference because God is greater.
In verses one through 23, he di he demonstrates
that God is greater, but Saul
doesn't view God as greater.
Jonathan. He believed God was greater than external
threats, the Philistines.
And when he's called out for eating honey,
he says, I'm ready to die.
Die. I don't care. He, he, he doesn't even think about it.
Jonathan believed God was greater even
than the opinion of his father.
He believed that God was greater than anything,
even in life and in death.
Why? Because his relationship with God
and the promises that God has given, proved to be true.
He knew it. One scholar says it this way.
Jonathan's faith filled actions had inter,
inadvertently brought about the defeat of two great enemies
of Yahweh's purposes.
One external, the Philistines
and one internal,
a misguided king Saul.
How true God is greater.
We can trust in God's provision protection.
We can trust in God's promises.
We learn to trust that God is greater.
Listen to me in relationship with God, not just coming
to church on a Sunday, going through the motions,
but not have a living relationship with God.
Students, young people listen to me.
Relationship with God is better than scrolling.
The zombie scrolling that we do. It's better.
He satisfies.
He takes us on a journey that's so exciting, so surprising.
God is greater. Lesson five.
There's a difference between the interior,
the exterior of life.
When we look at how Saul is presented, we can't help
but ask the question, what is going on inside
of Saul externally?
He's doing all the right thing, offering,
sacrificing, quoting the Bible.
And yet on the inside it is absolutely bereft.
We see a difference between his interior life
and his exterior life in terms
of the two rash vows that he makes.
Verse 24, 1 could no one can eat anything during the day
or else they'll be cursed.
Why? Because he wants his vengeance.
He doesn't care about his people.
The second rash vow, anybody who's sinned
and presented, prevented,
saw from hearing God will be killed.
Even if it's Jonathan, his son, verse 39,
he doesn't even care about his son, Jonathan.
He cares about himself Deep inside.
Saul has a problem. The wrong person is on the
throne of his life.
And friends, we can experience the same thing, can't we?
I mean, it's church might as well be honest.
Oftentimes, the throne
of our lives has the wrong person on it.
Job, money. That person that you're trying to pursue,
the throne of your life is only suited for one king.
And that's king Jesus.
It's the interior. I love the way that the Book
of Samuel gets at this.
We look at the outward,
but it's God that looks on the heart.
As God looks on our hearts this morning,
what's going on on the interior of our lives?
And maybe today, God is calling us
to have some house cleaning on the inside.
Maybe you need to lay some things down.
For some of us in this room, it may mean that we need
to step across the line of faith for the first time,
turn from our sins and turn to King Jesus.
Get the inner life right.
Lesson six, spiritual blindness is real.
Now, there's a couple of things
that we need to really focus on.
Like in verses 29 through 30.
What Jonathan says is, um, in verse 29,
my father has troubled this land.
That language of trouble shows up in another
place in the Old Testament.
Ready? Joshua Chapter seven. Anybody know your Bible?
Joshua chapter seven. It's the story of Aiken.
Aiken sinned against God
and it caused trouble for himself,
his family, and for Israel.
They commemorated that place where Aiken sin
by calling it aor trouble.
Saul uses that verb here.
It's like Saul is saying, oh man, I mean, Jonathan's saying,
Saul, my dad has a cord.
The entire land here, that's intentional.
And it shows us something about the interior life of Saul
and what's wrong, what's wrong with Saul?
It's not that he is a bad guy.
He's living in,
he's blind.
He doesn't even understand what he's doing.
He's causing trouble for everyone around him.
And he's blind to it. He can't see it.
In verse 37, there's there, there's a really que uh,
big question about, uh, why, why doesn't God answer
when Saul asks God didn't answer?
Why? Why doesn't he answer?
And he's throwing the rum in the th casting lots, trying
to figure out who's made the who's, who's the problem here?
And he's gonna kill whoever the problem is,
even if it's own son, right?
But the reality is the text is being so subtle here.
The problem is Saul,
he's about himself, not about God.
He's a problem, not his son, Jonathan,
so much so listen to this.
The king has uttered an oath.
And usually in the ancient world,
when a king says something, what he says goes,
but look what happens.
The people, they contravene the king's command.
Why? Because it's not a good command.
And the text is showing us that the king
that they need is not Saul.
Unbelievable. He's blind.
Have you ever seen the story or the cartoon?
Where's Waldo Etsy's now doing these commercials, right?
And Waldo's back, right? Where's Waldo? Where's Waldo?
Well, it's hard because he's always there,
but you can never see him.
Sometimes. That is how it is with God. God's present.
We just don't see him. That's Saul. God's present.
Saul can't see him. Where's Waldo? Where's the Lord?
Saul can't see him. He's blind.
He needs to have his spiritual eyesight regained.
And as we know, only Jesus can do that.
Spiritual blindness is real. Final lesson, very simple.
What I began with is where I leave us.
The story of one and two Samuel is really about the
king that Israel needs.
It's the king we need. And who is that?
Well, in this passage we see it's certainly not Saul
as we'll discover later.
It's not gonna be Jonathan because he dies with Saul.
Who is it? Well, it's David, not as you go through the book
of Second Samuel, the king we
need is coming.
His name is Jesus. He's the king
who provides perfect righteousness,
perfect peace, perfect joy.
He forgives our sins. He renews our lives.
He gives us life and life to the fullest.
That's the king that we need.
Who's on the throne of your heart and your life?
Some of you need to turn from your sin today
and turn to Jesus.